[Music]
hello everybody
welcome to our session today I'm Sandra
from Google security and this is
Jonathan the security architect from
Shopify together will be tell you
telling you guys about the new container
security products we just announced
today binarization
and how you can use it to secure your
software selection so I'll be going over
a overview for the product and how you
can use it in your production
environment and Jonathan here will give
you a live demo after my presentation
then we'll take questions in the end all
right um let's get started so what is
one of the top questions that DevOps and
security stakeholders and interpreters
have on their mind what is running
enterprise is run thousands of services
in their production clusters across
multiple environments and often times it
is very difficult to keep track exactly
what it's running I let alone how to
apply centralized consistent control
over this software um data leaks
security incidents data breaches are on
the rise and many of those are caused by
bad code running in chat in trusted
environment having access to super
sensitive data so code is the weak link
in many many enterprises security story
I've seen a lot of users that invest a
lot of energy and effort comfort for
configuring the perfect access control
policies to make sure only trusted
account can access sensitive data as
well as pushing production code this is
good but not enough because as
organizations grow as member of
applications grow as a number of
employees grow
it becomes increasingly difficult to
keep track of what kind deploy in the
production environment what I mean by
that so take an example um this user has
a bucket of customer critical
information in production super
sensitive and he has configured his
access control policy to make sure only
his production applications and a couple
trusted admins having access to this
bucket of critical information but
because of the application is VM based
it is very difficult to build new
versions and push new releases of this
application so it ended up running for a
long time and was running different
roles from different part of the
production offer from the our
organization needs to do things to
running application for example security
engineers in common and patch apply
updates when things becomes outdated
admins may have to come and restore the
software when it gets stuck software
engineers may have to come and manually
make adjustments because a new
requirement or get published citizens
change before you know it you have a
number of people and a number of paths
that can apply changes to production
software was this fairly broad attack
surface um a attacker or rogue employee
could come by and slip in a piece of bad
code to want the changes to the
production software
now wallah you have a security incident
so you may think that well that is
legacy software for you I plan to update
all my production infrastructure to use
containers I am good right let's take a
look so this user has a container
running in production it is true that
containers refine the software supply
chain you don't have a number of people
apply changes to the software directly
anymore
instead developers have to reviewed and
repose a container in order to apply any
changes to it because containers are
immutable
so now organizations have a centralized
to point where all changes to production
deployments are applied and a lot of
them take advantage of that - view -
baking streamlined security controls and
tests to make sure that all the
production changes are up to snuff
things like making sure it's beautiful
trusted sources making sure it passes
all unit tests making sure it clears
vulnerability scan making sure and
analysis static analysis don't find any
fault with a code and it has been
manually okayed by a quality control
engineer it is all good but it still
does not fundamentally change how
deployments are controlled it is still
account based deployment control which
means that if you have a employee or
attacker who stole the credential of an
employee have access to push code in
production Vic would still just bypass
all thoughts streamlines the ICD
controls and push a trusted piece of
code in production directly now that is
where binary authorization comes in play
miner Association makes sure that only
properly signed containers are deployed
to the kubernetes engine it gives you a
tool to define policies around what can
be deployed in addition to who can
deploy addressing the weakness in
account based deployed control mechanism
so let's take a look how it works
users have a piece of code that he has a
CCD pipe and set up around the code
through a set of required tests and
controls before pushing to production
minor authorization integrates with the
CIC BPI plan by having them producing a
signature as the image passes through
the individual stages in the pipeline so
a butor would sign a container that says
I'm the trusted pewter I am the one who
builds a container tests will sign a
container that says this container
passed my test pipeline vulnerability
signed the container
it doesn't find any known existing
vulnerabilities on it analysis you know
a QA engineers put their respective
signatures on this piece of image so by
the time and the image comes to be
deployed to production by neural
authorization is integrated into the gke
deploy api that will look at the
signatures are there produced by the
different stages in CIT PI plan compare
that against customer defined policies
on what can deploy in production and
then make a diploid stage of deploy
decision so now if you have an employee
with access to push code to production
comes along to push them untrusted code
it would fail because the image would
not have the required signatures on it
now you have code based deployment
controls so at a high level this is how
it works and we've worked with design
partners such as Shopify to make sure
that it can properly integrate into your
existing production setup we have a
number of features that I'm going to go
through with you today to see how you
may have to see how it works with your
existing infrastructure so first of all
you probably already have if you use
container you probably already have a
csv pipeline set up you want to make
sure that your process can be reused
across a large number of production
deployment you don't want a separate
repository a separate pipeline for each
environment or application that you
build binarization accommodates that by
defined policies at the wrong time
environment level what do I mean by that
I say you have two clusters rgk a prod
and a dev for the production environment
you want to make sure that a image has
to be signed off by also required CI CD
stages before it can run because it has
access to live customer data but for dev
environment you want to maintain
developer velocity
so as long as image has being
beautifully has passed the unit test
it's good to go
there are difference in deployed time
policy for this environment but we can
still use the same CI CD setup for a
production deployment you have to go
through the entire csv pipeline clear
all stages before it can be deployed but
for the dev environment you have the
options of build it test it take it out
of the pipeline um you know deploy it
staying there or if after running in
production eating them environment for a
while you like this container is good
I'm gonna promote it to production you
know have to duplicate any of your CD
setup you can just push it through the
remaining required tests and now it has
all the required signatures the same
image that was deployed to dev can all
be deployed to production so you can
maintain a centralized shared CI CD
process across offering environment
which is easier to manage I'm more
secure final authorization integrates
with the centralized metadata store are
hosted by Google container registry
it's called container analysis API we've
also announced this product today
um container analysis API is designed to
be the one-stop shop for all metadata
associated with a container so that a
centralized stakeholder can you think
has questions about a particular
container that is being deployed or that
it's running he can go in and check to
see you know what are all the
information what are all the things I
know about the content so as a container
goes through its beauties for example
the buter would generate a beaut record
indicating what are the source that was
used for this container what are the
packages that was included when was it
butyl beauty container a guru test the
tester can write a standardized metadata
about the test result
go through scanner standardized metadata
around vulnerability findings for the
for the for the image so by the times
image comes to deploy controls such as
binary authorization can take a look at
all the metadata that are produced in
the container analysis API and apply
policies apply controls to determine
what can deploy in production so content
so binary authorizations signature
format is just one of the metadata that
container analysis API supports um the
Google engineers has also published a
open source standard for called gracias
for this container metadata analysis API
it uses the same at a data format and
uses the same API format so that you can
collect and produce and collects this
information for your on-prem environment
binarization also published a kritis
open source project which is a open
source implementation of deploy time
enforcement with kubernetes very similar
to binary or Association which combined
was gracias you have the building blocks
to implement a similar enforcement flow
for your on-prem development deployment
similar to what we have here for
communities engine um if you use Google
GCP tools such as Google container
beuter and registry google container
registry vulnerability scanner there are
a set of metadata that's already
produced for you so if you your code is
viewed by google container build it will
already produce a beaut verifiable
Beauty record for you for every
container that it views and today that
is happening is stored in the container
analysis idea similarly when you push a
image into Google container registry it
gets scanned by the wall scanner which
is also announced today and will publish
a vulnerability findings
now while the most common use cases that
we hear from customers is I want to be
able to gate deployment
based on Bude and vulnerability
information the tricky thing with that
is every organization has a different
definition of what is acceptable and
interviewed and in availability findings
that is why we give you a tool a
open-source signer that you can use to
define what your organization's
requirements are for build and to sign a
butte and an ability record so the way
it works is the user would take the
signer apply to your own custom
configuration that says they say things
like in a butte record a will only sign
a container for to be okay to deploy if
the source come from these following
three repositories or I would only sign
a container to be vulnerability state
ready if it does not contain critical
vulnerability findings and when that
happens the signer issues the
attestation using a customer provided
key by the time the container reaches
production minor Association will look
up that attestation because the user
would would would put that in the policy
to say I would require attestation and
enforce to make sure only images with
proper Bude and vulnerability finding
records can deploy to the production
environment um we also understand so so
far we talked we told you about how only
signed
properly signed image images that a
beauty house can be deployed to your
environment but we also recognize that
not all images people wrong on their
production environment are Beauty houses
our popular third-party images such as
energy necks and Redis that a lot of
customers deploy but it's also a common
source of vulnerabilities in many
enterprise environment so to address
that issue
we support image whitelist in the policy
in banner our association policy so a
security stakeholder could say I
all of the Internet's are instances
deployed in my organization to be the
up-to-date vulnerability free one that I
deemed ok so he would put that in the
policy and when employee comes and try
to push the latest secure engine X image
the digest match and search appointment
go through but if somebody tries to push
the outdated vulnerable version of the
same sort of hard image it would fail
and generally the auto log so the
security team can review these incidents
later on and this then and therefore
secure your deployment environment by
association integrates with kubernetes
master to make sure it can apply
verification apply the policies to every
single deployment that goes through your
that goes to your production project so
when a deployer comes along the deployer
could be a human could be a automated
pipeline that's not matter it sends a
request to criminate his master that
says i am deploying digest fool with two
cluster bar which then would forward
this request to the emissions controller
which is part of the Illuminati's master
um if this project or this cluster has
banners you can turn on admissions
controller would forward this request
the banner association which then would
go look up all the signatures associated
with it come back verify those
signatures using public cheese defined
in the policy and return a verification
decision once kubernetes master receives
the decision it can then go ahead either
block or allah all all to deployment
what but but you know we understand that
production emergencies to happen woody
for your things are on fire so i'm gonna
push a non-conforming change we allow
that arm
it's called brie class so again deployer
comes along sets productions on fire i
have the fixed quick fix here let me
just push it through i will specify
break last flag and
request will reach kubernetes as usual
goes through the whole verification
process federalization says note this is
not conformant but kubernetes master
will say I'm overwriting it because
break glass
flag it sternal and this would generate
LD log so the break glass deployment
event would can be reviewed later on so
this is battery authorization coming
soon to beta which is announced beta
today the code will be available shortly
hopefully I have convinced you that code
based deployment control is more secure
than a comm based account based
deployment control and binary
Association would provide that for our
kubernetes engine we will support
runtime of policies associated with the
runtime environment at both project and
cluster levels you can define
enforcement at different granularities
will have integrated will have
integration with GC our vulnerability
scanner as well as the container butor
so that you can apply deploy policies
based on vulnerability findings and
build information will support
whitelisting trusted third-party images
so you can have standards across your
organization on what third-party image
to run in case of emergency break glass
well integrated was I am on order
logging so that you can review failed
attempts break last deployment events
later on after the fact we also want to
make it really easy for you to integrate
this into your CI CDP I plan to make it
easy for you to write finalization
signatures for image so we'll have
partner support from popular security
tools such as twistlock
popular CI CD tools such as copies and
jenkins to make it easy for you last but
not least we have open source reference
implementation for gracias and Critias
so you have the building block to
implement similar security controls for
your on-prem
deploy
all right so that's that concludes the
overview of mineralization and hopefully
I give you a taste of how to in how to
secure your software supply chain using
this new product that we've announced
next con will hand the floor to Jonathan
Jonathan will show you guys a demo on
binary authorization work in action and
combined with other security controls to
secure Shopify's production environment
Jonathan
[Applause]
cool look at that it works demos done
thanks yeah I wish so hey everybody my
name is Jonathan Pulsifer a production
security engineer at Shopify before we
get started on this just want to go over
what our production infrastructure looks
like at a pretty high level here so if
you are a developer at Shopify and you
have a repository that contains code and
you want to turn that into a service you
interact with this tool called services
DB which which is where all the robots
live so we're going to create your
production identities and these sorts of
things your kubernetes namespaces and
all that and the automation like like a
build type pipeline will also be added
for you so build kite is not too unlike
Google Cloud container builder and we're
gonna run through what that looks like
today after image is pushed up to up to
GCR we're gonna deploy it with a tool
called shipit and a gem which we've
open-sourced called kubernetes deploy so
please go check that out and once it
hits kubernetes there's a lot more
automation and magic that happens there
with our cloud buddies our cloud buddies
are the name for our custom kubernetes
controllers that help keep our cloud
fluffy at Shopify and further to that we
use a number of other GCP services to
help make our cloud go so the demo that
I have for you today is a PCI compliant
demo as a security person moving our
compliance environments into GK's been
it's been a large project that we've
been working on and so we've had the
need to to create these policies which
helped us remain compliant so Google
Cloud container builder comes PCI
certified out of the box so we don't
need to worry about that and we get some
added stuff for free like like standard
mentioned like the verifiable build
records and vulnerability findings so so
given that we've built the tool called
Voucher so this this slide is very
similar to the ones that you've seen
earlier where we've taken that open
source signer and well we've built
something so I'd like to show you what
that sonner looks like hopefully in real
time so what we're gonna do is run
through a two demo at two stations or
signatures that are created that are
going through these integrations that
Sandra talked about earlier
containing no vulnerabilities and
actually verifying the build record so
I'm going to flip over
to my build triggers what I've done here
is I have two source repositories in and
the in Google Cloud one it's called bad
and one it's called good and so we're
gonna run through those built some
containers what they're doing is they're
triggering on each new get tag that's
bushed so we're gonna we're gonna change
the docker files up we're gonna we're
gonna push some tags and we're gonna see
what voucher has in store for us today
maybe
so because luck demos are super fun I
actually haven't recorded any of this so
I'm gonna try to make it and look at
that it's super quick that's awesome so
I'm gonna explain sort of the lay of the
land here the bottom left pane we're
gonna in the bottom right the bottom
panes are the containers and the source
repositories that I talked about on the
left hand side we have our good
container and the right hand side we
have our bad outch ur has been built and
is listening in the top pane so we're
gonna go through and show you these
docker files for a good container we're
gonna make some changes to it just for
funsies so instead of echoing hello
we're gonna echo hello - I just want you
to note the from directive that we're
using here so alpine as hard as it may
be to work with in production actually
does not come stock with any
vulnerabilities fingers cross and
nothing's changed since the last dry run
so what I've done is I just changed the
docker file I'm gonna add the docker
file gonna read a little commit message
and say hi next I'm going to tag this
with next demo and I'm going to get push
and get push tags now hopefully when
this is up what's going to happen is
every time that container builder
finishes a build and puts it into GC air
it's going to create an event on pub/sub
and so I'm listening to that that build
notification so Voucher should fingers
crossed over that builds done pick that
up and do its thing
so while that's happening I'm going to
show you see second docker file I just
want you to notice the from line don't
mean to trash Ubuntu but like come on
alright fine so we're just gonna do the
same thing we're going to change your
docker file we're gonna add it
I'm gonna read a commit message and then
we're gonna get push and you put get
pushed eggs I do the tag
yeah good enough forgot my work anyway
so hopefully that's all done now so I'm
gonna walk you through this output that
we have from voucher I tried to make it
as pretty as possible for the demo so
here's what happened so you can see that
there's a build event that we've
inserted that this this new container
this new image with a job and what it's
doing is actually gonna go through and
pull the container analysis API to see
if there if it's noticed that any new
images have been pushed and see if it's
gonna run through any analysis and we
can see that it's found no discovery so
it's going to wait for some and it found
that the vulnerability scanner is gonna
go through and do its analysis that
actually finished and no vulnerabilities
were found in this container at the same
time it's going to run the provenance
check the provenance check is verifying
that the image in the verifiable build
record its checksum actually matches the
images that we want to deploy it that's
actually hit GCR so we're actually
making sure that the artifact has
maintained its check sums all through
the pipeline snake-oil is the name of
the check that we made that ensures that
containers contain no vulnerabilities so
we can see that this past because alpine
is pretty cool with that and actually
worked as expected I just quit voucher
here because we're done with it for now
but we see the second build event for
our bad container and we see it's doing
the same thing it's waiting for analysis
and oh look had found 32 vulnerabilities
in this container and just you know for
fun I would decided at surface one of
the critical vulnerabilities so we have
a critical vulnerability in G let's see
two to seven and there's a CD that's
associated with it so this is makes sort
of CEQA a little bit easier when we have
to determine which which vulnerability
is actually present in an image so we
can see further that like after all
those checks have been done we can see
the ACTA stations are being created so
in the good container we have two ACTA
stations created two signatures for
provenance and for snake-oil and we see
that the SATA station was created for
provenance for the bad container but
actually failed because it contained
vulnerabilities and we don't want any
vulnerabilities and the images that we
deployed today so earlier we talked
about this this policy so we're gonna
take a look at the policy that we have
set up for the clusters in our project
so this policy for binary authorization
contains some white listing because if
we did in white list these three
repositories my kubernetes cluster with
the stars on G key so what I've just
done done is this glob to every every
image inside of those juicy our
repositories has been white listed for
the purposes of the demo please do not
do this at home okay so I'm gonna run
through the rest of this we have some
cluster admission rules so earlier we
said that we can we can specify a policy
on a project level and on a cluster
level so we're gonna try to demo both of
those today so the cluster admission
rules I have running in Canada or North
America North East one a test cluster in
an evaluation would require two station
so what this means is that any image
that deploys a binary authorization is
going to match these these data stations
and you can see that they're named
Providence and snake-oil just as we
talked about for all the other clusters
running in this project we only want to
make sure that it's built by a trusted
identity and that the image actually was
validated so moment of truth we're gonna
try to deploy some images we're gonna
grab our our good shot that passed then
we're going to keep CTL run good times
we're going to try to run the thing so
we're gonna do also come on come on hey
look at that
then we're also gonna grab the bad shot
the one that failed and we're going to
keep CTL run bad times we're gonna
deploy those you know so what do we all
expect what happened well I I would
certainly expect based on my policy to
have one good times deployment and no
bad times deployment so let's check it
out and see what happened so we could
get some pods and sure enough the only
one good times pod is running because
both add two stations have been created
based on the policy that we created for
our project and in the specific case our
cluster admission rules so like cool but
what does that mean for a developer how
can we get any sort of actionable
feedback you know where where does this
live
how did that fail I'm a command-line
person so I'm gonna get the replica sets
that have been created here a deployment
in kubernetes is like the highest level
of abstraction which creates replica
sets and further to that creates pods so
we've created the deployment object and
said hey cool we want this container to
run and it created a replica sense and
hey cool we're gonna try to start this
pod for you you can see that bad times
has one container desired but none are
ready so we're gonna see what happened
with that boom talk about error
messaging so for those who don't know
kubernetes controllers are unlike TLDR
for loop so it's just gonna keep trying
to do this thing over and over and over
again and every time that it tries we
have an error creating the pod it's
forbidden because it's an image policy
webhook back end denied one of our
images right so every time that it gets
deployed there's some shenanigans and
web hooks that fire around that helped
us do its thing it was denied by the
attestation authority we cannot find any
snake-oil at the stations for this image
such that it failed neat so what about
on all the other clusters just to prove
that the policy works
I created a yellow cluster in here and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna try to
run the bad times image the same one
that was attested earlier with voucher
and fingers crossed it should deploy to
my yellow cluster looks like it then we
have one bad x pod running so this sort
of proves that the policies are working
as intended I'm just gonna bring up that
policy to show you what that looks like
everything's annulled these days such as
the policy and so it's pretty easy to
read it should be easy to read for not
just security people but for other
engineers and operations people alike
it's important that technologies like
this are are human readable and easy to
digest or else we can't implement them
properly so further to that bin authors
not just a command-line suite it does
come with a fancy GUI now thanks to our
UX folks over here who made
the way it is today so I put some human
readable descriptions on our honor
signatures or our testers just to just
to say what this is actually doing such
that you know if I name something
willy-nilly like snake oil that doesn't
mean anything to anybody but having a
human readable description they're in a
nice pretty GUI makes it really easy for
those other folks to understand you see
what's going on so that's it for my demo
thank you very much what I'm gonna do is
continue presenting a couple slides so
we hit beta today which is super
exciting and now our websites live so
you can see it at a cloud at google.com
slash binary authorization now we are
gonna be in the demo booth on the ground
floor of Moscone South later so if you
want to come hang out with us that would
be awesome and we are running some code
labs for this sander I think there there
are code labs for this in Muskogee
there's a cool lab area you must go nice
also where he can go and get it has some
machines set up we can get some hands-on
experience working through cool lab so
because we're a security talk and we
like our security people there's a lot
more on container security happening
here at next you know that it's been
it's been the number one sort of topic
these days which is super exciting for
me
but the one that we did really want to
highlight is preventing the next major
security breach
down to the bottom right corner tomorrow
at 1:15 that is the talk about the juicy
air vulnerability scanner so if you want
to learn more about how that works and
talk to the folks who made that happen
tomorrow afternoon is is where that's
going to be all right cool so with the
Russians
if there are any questions there are
mics actually on on either side so if
you'd like to be recorded such that we
can all hear you - that would be sick we
got one over here the less weight other
left stage left sort of thing
eeny meeny miny moe rock-paper-scissors
Hey I guess I'll jump in the binary
authorization output that you were
getting on the screen from the command
line there is that available in
stackdriver like can we push that to our
stackdriver logging as well so uh bye
normalization logs all the deployment
events to auto log which pushes to stack
driver I believe so you should be able
to get that in fact driver without there
there are two different pieces to this -
right the the EV the actual kubernetes
replica set error as well which should
be just found in regular kubernetes
engine logs or other event logs when
binary authorization creates its own
distinct audit logs in these
circumstances so like the images blocked
you're gonna have your regular kate's
events that saying oh we can't start
this pod because reasons you can find
that information there or in the audit
log as well the other log is up sorry
it's an auto lock it's basic it's the
same place where GK yeah surface they're
all in log so if you have that set up
you should be all good all right so is
this something we can bring in like say
if we're not using gke and we've got our
own kubernetes set up on some other
cloud providers it something we could
bring in to use so we do have a open
source reference implementation as I
mentioned it's open source so we love to
hear your your knees and get your
contribution but as is yes it is
something that you can set up and to
work with the open source criminal case
is probably gonna take a little bit of
configuration because it's not a hosted
solution you have to write of course
pieces together but yeah I thought so I
just want to confirm thank you
github.com / graphics github.com /
graphic read ease for both their
reference implementations thank you
I so I have two questions the first one
is so there's no extra steps that you
have to take like a deploy time for
example could you use an Orchestrator
like helm and still do this so every
deployment that goes through gke III so
you can you should just be able to
deploy as usual shouldn't be any the
deployment process for the vast majority
of deployments should it change unless
you're deploying something that does not
meet policy yet there are some
integration work you have to do with
your C sed pipelines to produce a
signature okay and then how would you
apply the policy is it just a g-cloud
command yeah we have a particular
command and a UI then can't you find the
policy yeah okay thank you
I'm curious about where the private
signing Keys live especially if you're
using the open source stuff and can't
use the integrated yeah so -
unfortunately you'll have to manage your
own private key for the for the open
source version as well as for the hosted
version for now we are looking at
different integrations we'll love to
hear your requirement on where we should
take this and make it more easier to use
for you in the case of the demo it's
just PGP keys and we have a tool called
a JSON at Shopify that we use just to
encrypt it and keep it in the same
source repository so GPG in a dream are
you planning - are you planning to offer
a hosted like voucher signing service or
is that something that we have - that's
definitely something that we're thinking
of I'll come talk to me afterward and
like to get your requirements on that
how does this compare to they call it
container signing image signing with a
product like twist lock is this
basically the same or are there
differences that
you know haven't necessarily been called
out know we actually integrate with with
twistlock
so if you're a twistlock user and you
have your scanner set up and you have
your scanner policy set up so while your
image passes the twistlock scan or twist
lock would sign the image which can then
be enforced at deploy on our gke there
are other types of products out there
maybe like would you be like talker
content trusts things like that that
also involves image signing but that's
more around the software distribution
protection versus a sort of provenance
enforcement so the difference there is
well software's are distributing an open
Internet environment they may get
altered while it's moved from
repositories repository and signatures
such as darker content trust makes sure
that the software has not been altered
it comes from a trusted source a pattern
authorization takes sort of a slightly
different approach focusing our largely
collaborative environment which is
enterprise organization and you want to
make sure that the software you deploy
has passed certain tests that are hosted
by you that you have control okay all
right great no more questions um as John
mentioned we're gonna be at the demo
booths around 2 o'clock so if you want
to come and check out and hell with us
you're welcome and thank you all for
coming thanks
[Music]